(dramatic music)
- [Woman] Growing up Mormon.
- [Man] Growing up in Yelyas Church.
- [Woman] Being Mormon.
- [Man] I felt like being
gay just wasn't an option.
- [Woman] We were about as
evil as a thing can get.
- [Man] The church hasn't
really acknowledged us.
- [Man] I was ultimately
told to suppress it.
- [Woman] I dealt with
a lot of self-hatred.
- [Man] I thought about suicide a lot.
- Utah's problem is that our
suicide rate has been climbing in youth,
and that's appalling.
- These kids are being lost,
but there's no discussion in the church.
As Mormons we need to have
some serious discussions, and
look in the mirror and figure
out what we're doing wrong.
- The church has made it fairly clear
where they stand on gay relationships,
and so if you can't get on this ship,
those of us that are in the trenches
are gonna make it happen.
And that's what Mama Dragons do.
- It's very cool to see
this grass root network
of women giving people hope,
and giving people answers.
- In the book, How To Be
a Perfect Mormon Mother,
there's no chapter, how
to parent your gay kid.
Mama Dragons is helping
to right that chapter.
(string music)
- Before my son came out,
I felt like being gay was an abomination.
I felt like it was a choice.
I didn't really ever question anything.
I was asked by my leaders
to canvas my neighborhood
and get signatures to protect the marriage
between man and a woman.
And I was a good little soldier.
My whole thought process
changed when my son came out.
- The Mormons tend to be a
pretty conservative bunch,
socially, and current
Mormon doctrine and policy,
really doesn't have a place
for the our LGBT kids.
- A lot of people are fearful that
having their LGBT kids will impact
their relationship with the church,
it may impact their
standing with the church,
they're not willing to reach out
and go to the next step.
- For a lot of Mormon moms,
having a kid come out is the start
of a real faith crisis for them.
Mama Dragons is a support group
for Mormon moms with LGBT children.
One of the things it does
is help moms not feel alone,
not feel like they're the
only one walking that path.
We figured out that
Grayson was transgender
when he was 16 about halfway through
his junior year of high school.
I was, you know, supportive
of his transition,
but for about the first year and a half,
I didn't know a single other, Mormon mom,
with a transgender kid.
I don't want other moms to
feel as alone as I felt.
- In five years, 10
years, if the Mama Dragons
still exist, we can have a huge base.
There's usually 10-15,
every week that we add,
so that's 60 new women a month so,
720 a year.
- Most Mama Dragons that
I work with and know,
have their finger and their
pulse on at least 15 kids.
Talking through how they
might be able to come out
to their parent or how
to handle their situation
with their parents.
Part of that is, you know, trying to
help them with suicide
prevention, understanding.
We're saying, oh no, that's
not gonna happen on my watch.
- You know an average of 557
Utahans die by suicide every year.
It is the leading cause of death
in youth ages 10-17 in Utah.
(dramatic music)
- No one is acknowledging
that our LGBTQ people feel so ostracized,
by the religion that they were raised in.
- Here, by default,
if you don't fit in your church community,
you then don't fit into your neighborhood
and then you don't fit into your school.
- The data is very clear,
that young people who don't
have a good support network,
in particular young
people who feel rejected
by their families, are
at much higher risk.
We have to change our whole culture,
about how we treat LGBT
young people in the church.
- I've met a lot of Mama Dragons
because I went and met them for lunch,
and then I told them about the group
and asked if they wanted to be a part.
Hey, Jill.
So meeting with them one on one
and letting them share
anything they wanna share.
- Anna was afraid to come out to us,
before she came out she was telling us,
oh, there's a kid at school who's gay,
and he's being bullied;
but it's like, that was her.
And she was afraid to tell us that.
- She wanted to see what
your response would be.
- Mm-hmm.
She was testing the waters,
you know what I mean?
It's like if, you know,
are my parents gonna say,
"Well, don't hang out with that kid,
"stay away from that kid,"
you know, it makes me sad.
She slept on the floor of
our bedroom for a month.
You know, it's like I
couldn't leave her alone
and knowing there are people like Alison,
you know, who ...
- Kind of experienced our worst nightmare.
- Yeah.
- Wanna show them your smile?
Stockton was my long-awaited boy.
He was, the happiest kid ...
(baby babbles)
spoiled rotten.
- [Stockton] Up, shake, lay.
- I would say Stockton
was very comfortable
with being gay;
I think Stockton was very
uncomfortable with being alone.
(dramatic music)
- That was June 27th of 2016.
If someone would've told me that,
I would be coming back
to my son being gone,
I wouldn't have ever guessed it.
(dramatic music)
- I don't know;
I don't know what kind of
just pushed him that day.
I think that's one of the hardest things,
not knowing, you know, as a mom,
and if I could've,
I would've done anything,
to keep him here.
- We hear about the gay kids
who are taking their lives,
but now it really did happen,
it wasn't just someone said it,
I live it; it's real.
(dramatic music)
- You can't sit and see a kid suffer;
or see a kid talk about
how they're worth nothing,
and that their only two options is either
to leave the church, or to commit suicide.
I've dealt with those kind
of situations with kids.
(dramatic music)
- If I didn't have Jill,
part of me thinks I probably
wouldn't be here right now.
How are you?
Suicide is something that I've
struggled with for a while.
There was a time I even
thought that my parents
would rather me die than to marry a man,
and so it's something that,
logically, I thought made the most sense.
I was having a really,
really, really hard time,
and so I was talking to a friend about it,
and he said, "Well, I
have someone I can put
"you in contact with, her name is Jill
"and she's a Mama
Dragon," and I had no idea
what in the world the Mama Dragons were.
So it's been interesting
that, in the space
of a couple years, Jill has now become
such an integral part of my life.
- We're just his home; he is welcome here;
we love Shane as a family,
but I think it is taking a
long time for him to really,
start to realize how wonderful he is.
He's had to go through
a lot of dark times.
- It's very hard to be both openly gay
and a very active, serious
member of the church.
You know, how do I choose between,
literally, two parts of who I am?
I think that's a challenge
that lots of people
had to experience.
- Sometimes my youngest daughter will
ask me: "How do you go to a
church that hates your son?"
And, it's a hard question to answer.
- Hey.
- Hey, how are you?
- I think if I were to categorize it,
I feel like I'm in a bit of
a faith crisis a little bit.
I pray and sometimes I feel like,
you know, is anybody listening to me?
My relationship with
Heavenly Father and Jesus,
is kind of a work in progress.
- You know religion and spirituality
are two different things, so
I really decipher between,
the church and the gospel;
and the gospel will always be part of me.
- The Gospel of Jesus Christ is perfect.
The church is imperfect, even
though the gospel is perfect.
I look at, you know, the
leaders of our church today,
and say, well, I wish they were a little
more loving and compassionate
and understanding of the
experiences of LGBT people.
But, for me, I know that
being a member of the church
is where God has called me to be.
- I got a card from a family
in Idaho, oh, on the back it says,
"Jill, thanks for loving
and accepting my son
"and for being such a positive
impact for good in his life.
"You will never know how
much that means to us."
And that's from his mom.
'Course that always means a lot to me.
(string music)
- [Man] This life is meant to live.
- [Woman] Finding one
friend, finding two friends.
I can make a world of a difference.
- [Man] That day will come
when you can be yourself.
- [Woman] When you have
that support system,
it's sheer bliss.
- The Mama Dragons
mission is to help people
to see that there's
hope that they can find
a community in which they feel loved.
I know that if they're doing it with me,
they're doing it with other people.
- I look forward to the day when
Mama Dragons doesn't need to exist.
When having a LGBT kid is just as ordinary
as having a kid who's left-handed.
I feel like there's more Stocktons within
the walls of the church,
and there's more parents who
need to know that you can love your kid.
I believe that there will be a day
that I will be reunited with him.
And if not, I'm gonna be really pissed.